Well,
good day, I greet you, Andrés González, and
these are the most relevant news
for Thursday, September 9,
while most of the casinos in the
valley have opened the Texas Station and the
Fiesta casinos in Henderson and North Las
Vegas remain closed for almost a month.  year the
texas station hotel and casino has
remained closed and has only been
used as a coronavirus testing and
vaccination clinic the
station company almost tells us that it
continues to monitor the economy and
also how it raises the properties that they
already have open and that for now  there
are no plans to reopen these casinos
this year
and a reminder to the public about
the large scale drills that will
be taking place at the airport
marked today
the community is informed that there will be a large number of
units from all agencies
emergency personnel present such as firefighters,
paramedics and police officers will
also hear sirens so they
will be alert to the  public not to be alarmed
as it is a simulation of the
federal evasion agency that is required to be
done every three years
fans wanting to attend the game of
the radios on monday at lee
jane stadium must be vaccinated for this
very reason vaccines will be offered
before  of the game in the stadium on
Friday, Saturday and Sunday and for people
who are partially vaccinated,
that is, they have only received one vaccine
, they will be forced to use face masks
to enter the stadium, those
people who are fully
vaccinated are asked to upload their
data to the clear application to
verify their status before the game
on Monday
and people who want to get vaccinated today there
will be three clinics one at
the county government center from 2 to 4 in the
afternoon another at the
nevadas' state college campus  until 1:30
in the afternoon and another one at Chaparral High School
, vaccinations will be given
until 3:30 in the
afternoon.  Let's see the weather forecast
summer begins to announce its
farewell but not before heating up the
valley for a few more days by Thursday
anticipation not high 105 degrees with
fairly dry breezes and similar for the
weekend so stay
hydrated and  Take care of yourself, have a
nice day, I inform you in 3 gonzález and
this was your brief news
now in Spanish
[Music]